Elizabeth grey organic
second ball in wood
typically the Khan visiting assistant
professorship brings young architect
educators who are schools offering the
opportunity to lead an intense to go and
if they were issues seminar but with
great dancing the situation is somewhat
if they are young they are friends
committed to many of us Alan forget is
already a member and four days first
year the gray is not for a long time in
school so this is Perry
the new palace controlled special
promise for us call this method
Elizabeth gray holds a Bachelor of Arts
in both English and architecture as well
as the Master of Architecture from their
99 400 independent practice and was
joined two years later by alain rienzi
holds a Bachelor of Arts in history from
Brown University at the master of
architecture can be ale where he was
awarded William Wirt Winchester militia
mountains ocean Lisa gray is combined
practice with national teaching of
history and clearly in jail and join
miami against the advanced design at
Roger Williams University the work of
array or gassy partnership is notable
for its inspired craftsmanship
environmental sensitivity and elegant
sense of composition while much of that
work has been realized in Connecticut
the partnership has recently begun to
attract clients from wider field and
will be grandstand
Island New York receive the New York
Public design vision awards 2005 that
was selected by the articular league or
its emerging architects award in 2012
american academy of arts and mothers
trans identity with an arts and letters
or more in architecture please join me
in welcoming the fall 2014 xeikon
visiting assistant professor as they
remember the lector scarcity
so to us and sitting there trying to
chart our course architecture
particularly remember Penn Station 373
and the height of his powers is
architected creator institutions and
even new nations are textural identities
and all the sum we added mysterious
presence in our lives but probably well
our appropriate ability conference
expansion will speculate anytime nature
for the practices how he liked my fate
buildings out of ideas in the time we've
got we studied cons buildings that his
regular cryptic statements like the time
i talked to a brick and he said what do
you want right the right oven I like
tarnish and he said what i want to but
arches are expensive I can use it help
people in
what do you back right said so the
serious like this roll around really
feel I think it means something I'm not
sure really what I mean but if it means
anything it means doing things like
being at Yale with Khan is your teacher
which unfortunately we didn't experience
positive questions there things very
long on the immaculate perhaps maybe
we'll be short on operating instructions
you know it makes us wonder when we
think about on an appropriate we do
experts here tonight wonder what Khan's
life projects / tell us that short in a
way like project a man is so too
mystical a presence but build buildings
power physical as well as Kurt you
didn't choose to speak of money lost
some tears shed sweat exuded blood let
he spoke out about how to make villains
of it but elliptically Olympic way of
amines messages cotton was of course
experimenting with any available means
that executed on magnificent vision for
nation's capital speaks of a different
time and press different cultural
motives but it doesn't admit constrained
difficult so this evening we propose
something of an analysis and exchange
taking as our theme lionel robbins the
former head of the london school of
economics with lionel robbins definition
of economics and in the spirit of full
disclosure I should say that we're not
economists really what we are are people
exploring not money or finance the
architectural demands practical
constraints perhaps verging on austerity
and material means is our currency and
in the spirit of full disclosure I
should say that Lisa and I have never
after 25 years of practice lectured
together so this is a little bit of an
exchange an economic exchange of
approach content and time that's right
test run Malcolm did so Ellen and I even
when were here i think both knew that
building would be the place where we
felt that our ideas would best play out
maybe that's part of the DNA here at
Yale maybe especially at that time we do
think that building is the medium
through which architectural ideas are
most forcefully and unforgivingly
rest so we knew that we wanted to work
material to manipulate games facility of
what we feel are architectures special
tools and we explore material processes
and impacts like texture surface form
space light scale contrast environmental
analysis fabrication and production and
sight among many others so these really
became the basis of our of our focus
together when we launched our practice
and today we are officially too but
actually many many practices at our
place down on crown street gray or
ganske architecture and jake
design-build where we take on really
omnivorous ly architectural design
construction management fabrication
interior design wood and metalworking
site design quantitative environmental
analysis and we really merge all of that
into a kind of tangle of processes that
involve reflection and documentation
representation testing assessment
execution really what we collectively
call design so I would characterize our
approach actually is one of extreme
earnestness and maybe even a delusional
sense of taking on every design a
building challenge we look for all
building types we love different
locations and sites we embraced many
different kinds of client groups even
teaching assignments and we're
occasionally reckless maybe in our
material experimentation but we are
dogged in our beliefs that a life and
architecture and we hope also in
practice is the orchestration of large
themes executed at a small in particular
scale maybe rather than one of hyper
specialization so just a few words about
our approach and a few projects and some
uses along with some provisional
conclusions so here's an early project
up in northwest connecticut it's too
much of our workers Canaan Connecticut
as Bob said and it this was really the
insertion of a very tiny building into a
protected watershed
which is now Christine landscape it's a
landscape that generates energy clean
energy for the building where the
building really just simply tries to fit
in to create a quiet place and at this
time in our work we really had a passion
for exploring the expression of
construction as a source of scale and
detail and of course the manipulation of
daylight which is a theme I think
throughout our work I'm in here an early
test of material fabrication such as the
sort of CNC had slide that you see there
and we had also I think an interest in
blurring the distinctions between inside
and outside and a predilection to draw
and design every detail no matter how
small and to plan its manufacture to
care about how it would wear and how it
would perform but ultimately this
project became an interest in helping
buildings to limit the intensity of
their construction we saw firsthand the
work that was involved in making this
tiny building and then in covering up
the scars of its of its construction so
we gained really honest I think an
interest in assembly and prefabrication
of elements as a means of limiting
disruption and of course also
controlling and increasing quality
because this beautiful landscape the
source of the ground source heat pump
and and what beautiful wetland habitat
in a protected watershed actually had to
be remediated so this is what it was
like when we got there and so through
this we had to confront ideas about
disruption and about managing resources
and about the impacts of undertaking
architectural building action and we
just sort of charted there there's the
town in Connecticut the network of roads
that were served by this quarry that it
was in operation for decades before our
client acquired this property and
charged us with restoring a pond there
so so this was a lesson for us that this
perfectly crafted little pavilion was
really part of a much larger legacy of
building impacts so we were trying to be
an environmental exemplar in the
performance and construction of that
building but we realized that we needed
to pull the frame out and understand
that the boundaries of the project were
far greater than we had originally
understood here's David plowed ins
beautiful photograph of taconite pellets
at Bethlem steel ironic and kind of
horrifying but also very beautiful and
john wightman architect architecture
speaks with the corpse in its mouth I
think John was was talking at the time
about the burden of history really the
history of dead white men not about
environmental devastation but the phrase
we think works very well to try to get
at the impact the range of impacts that
we're interested in understanding
another early project that taught us
about project limits and instructed us
some what constitutes the work of a
project so this is a pristine nature
conservancy a bridge was wanted but
really no one could step into the
landscape so an organizing feature of
the project became limiting its impact
so we are designed was a sort of narrow
ribbon that we threaded across the
ravine pinning down onto ledge
introducing no concrete of course and
trying to have his light of touch as
possible but we also realized that we
had to take a straw an interest and a
responsibility for construction
sequencing so prefabrication was very
important here material handling how to
get these 75 foot long blue lamps from
the factory in upstate New York to the
site here in Connecticut so that we
could drop them in
with a huge boom crane and that then the
folks who built the bridge could
actually use the bridge as their staging
deck and they could stay out of the
wetland too so I guess the conclusion of
this project as a lesson for us was
really that project sequencing is a part
of the design and we think that the the
project kind of express is in a way that
that that early construction technique
another project right here in new haven
for wonderful client who had a visionary
idea about rescuing this this this kind
of urban artifact very beautiful from
the early 19th century and charged us
with actually fitting a lot of users
into a very tight shell so it's a
recording studio it's a performance
space with all of the kind of technical
infrastructure that that those uses
demand it's also a public space for
gathering in a bar downstairs there's an
office at the back the top right for
managing the business and then there's a
two bedroom house inside so it was a
what it was really a project about you
kind of a Rubik's Cube challenge about
fitting all of these uses into this
existing shell and the idea of shells as
a light delivery system there in the
middle of the section kind of bringing
light deep into the middle of the
building because it was landlocked on
east and west only with South light and
North light so the idea about shells
became a kind of organizing feature of
the project so an idea that they could
give identity to the to the building
that they would organize space that they
would deliver light and give character
and scale and understanding that all the
elements in this little in this tight
little project had to do double-duty
list such as the concrete s buttress
that we introduced when we removed the
carriage floor to bring light down into
the into the space below and buttresses
that we also are you
to make space but that this shelf which
really is tunable and Alan will talk
about that in a moment a hot is a highly
formed sculpted actually instrument
itself whose origin is manipulating
sound and we were worried in a way that
there was the building was so tightly
packed as there wasn't really any
breathing room we did uncover the
beautiful architectural elements of its
construction in the spaces upstairs and
we've gained some height there but we
wondered whether the spaces were too
tight to be comfortable and and I think
in a way but this project taught us was
that actually it's the spaces between
these elements that really kind of
became charged for us that these joints
were really where the space was
happening so that taught us a lot about
kind of tightness of planning an
architectural opportunity so there it is
contributing wonderfully to the
neighborhood you our neighborhood
another story about a building that
really is about the relationship of a
very special community to its values and
how those values might play out in the
expression of a building here Fairfield
University there's this beautiful
standard of American beech trees that
actually had been kind of ignored and
forgotten by the University and on the
edge of the second growth forest and
this became our site and middle of the
school and this is a move across Jesuit
institutions across the country to to to
move out of the large dormitory
buildings that has what were large
numbers of men and now into smaller
buildings to accommodate a dwindling
order but it's an opportunity it was a
fair field and has been in other places
for this group to express their their
commitment to simplicity and living
lightly on the land so our initial kind
of diagram with the steep site would
seem always to get very steep sites
hardly ever get flat ones which is a lot
of times a great opportunity but always
complex you know so our diagram became
kind of merging between the outreach to
the public which is an important part of
their apostolic mission spaces for
public gathering kind of in the middle
stepping down the section and then how
simple rooms for the men looking out
across as beech trees so it seemed like
it's pretty straightforward proposition
and also the group came to us with what
looked like an extremely straightforward
program very organized they knew
themselves well they knew what they
needed they knew what the how everything
you did to touch so we went to work and
I guess I should also say that we we
seem always to get new building types
you know we're never quite qualified for
them but we we do our best and so we we
took all these elements and we created
this diagram which I think wouldn't be
called a great diagram here in the
school but it was the guiding diagram
for us and it you know had an organizing
principle at the overlaps of all of
these elements and then we sort of range
those elements on the plants of
administrative wing on the top a kind of
a pinwheel plans for the public spaces
in the middle where the men invite
sometimes their guests there and are
often in community with each other and
then the very the cereal kind of simple
rooms along the bottom of the page and
the building is extremely simple and
it's in its interior expression its main
job is to be in relationship to the
beech trees which we cleared out second
birth form and exposed as a beautiful
asset on the site cantilevered the
living room out to stay away from the
roots of the trees and the large porch
which faces east to the to the
University as part of their mission of
kind of being open a door always open to
the community into the students and then
the beacon which when lit really shows
where the chapel is so bringing daylight
down into that Chapel as it faces east
and this large sort of front door to the
campus in the cantilevered living room
out over this gabion baskets system
which again seems simple took actually
some fighting on the part of the men
there was an interesting kind of story
about the relationship a multi-headed
client between these
this group of very thoughtful
intellectual men in the University which
I think was a little bit worried about
the simplicity actually of the building
and we probably we never would have been
able to accomplish something quite so
abstract and even osteo without the full
commitment of of this group of men so
you know it was it was a pretty
cost-effective building it's not a fancy
construction type but we took some steps
to bring daylight in in careful ways
such as the cowl here in the section so
that we never would have glare coming
directly into the chapel and then the
sort of lit from the top and the sides
all at all times of the day and then of
course just a simple simple move of
offsetting the apertures in the chapel
wall so that religious objects would
would be washed with daylight but there
would be no views to the outside which
is appropriate for a space of devotion
when the sort of simple repetitive men's
rooms which they actually tell us they
feel like they're in tree houses which
makes us happy and again just a
relationship for the simple glue onto
the brick baby and the recycled brick
gabion walls and really that's the
palette of the building and there it is
I'm talking to it it's each trees and I
think you know this concept of austerity
was was something that was that they
that they wanted us to express and so
our main kind of learning experience
from this building was understanding how
these Jesuitical vows of poverty and
simplicity and living lightly on the
land could really inform an
institutional identity and how that
could play out in architecture which is
a concept we've got a very powerful and
actually a great privilege to work on so
just a couple of words that some
residential projects here is a little
concept sketch for a tiny cottage for a
couple who contacted us and had a really
large house and they were really looking
for a much
more compact simple space so you can see
the site plan with their you know sort
of 8,000 square foot house for two
people and then down on the right where
once the 19th century funk acid stood
which we thought we could say it
couldn't be safe so it became clear that
we were going to be building a new house
to accommodate them it wasn't entirely
clear what they were going to use the
building for maybe a caregiver maybe a
study but the bigger idea was that it
would be a place of quiet and simplicity
for them and here's one of the clans a
wonderful man who's an archivist and
historian here at Yale in in the neatest
version of his study so this translated
into an idea of giving them in a way you
know a place away from from their home
and so there they are sitting out on
their deck with the building opened up
and so this this also became a kind of a
study and how small can a building be on
a site you know how can it as a site and
kind of step away and let the site
really be what's present and what's the
smallest move we can make to kind of get
the head height that we need we're very
limited on the bill on the zoning
envelope here so here's a sort of
peekaboo window in the sedum roof but
then how big can the building feel
inside so so how how much dimension do
you actually need and then what elements
are present other than dimension in
terms of making space so that the
project really for us was a kind of
exercise and trying to crack a building
open you know to try to sort of open it
at the seams so that it would bleed out
into the landscape and light would bleed
into it and it's series of
investigations into different
utilitarian qualities is needed the
stairs and what's the latest way that we
could kind of handle them how could we
hide the kind of works of the space so
that it would answer their their wish to
be in a space of a kind of simplicity
and contemplation
a play of kind of inside and outside the
relationship between the operable
windows and the flat ones that kind of
interest that we have in kind of surface
versus depth and we found we didn't
expect that it was wonderful the way the
building reflected its surroundings when
it was finished and just a brief word
about clients they're very important and
here they are and they actually I think
what they ended up doing is spending
pretty much all their time in this
building sort of never in the 8,000
square foot house next door which is of
course we felt was a wonderful
compliment and then another client with
a different set of goals and this is a
project we were working on had around
the same time that the cottage cottage
was finishing and when we proposed to
our client Simon tuna and who creative
director Barney's and hilariously
describes himself as a simple window
dresser and you know we showed and
concepts which we've used at the Kelly's
about a very simple interior with just
light and and bleached bamboo and he
said he would sooner slit his wrists and
live in an all blond cheerier so we
realized that we had gets to work in a
different direction and so I show you
this really because these two projects
were taking place concurrently and in
this in this project our work we really
regarded our work as a kind of backdrop
for the exuberance of their lives and
their collections and they're sort of
you know fabulous clutter and here
here's Simon's husband Jonathan you know
who who really they they sort of took a
quiet corner of the world and filled it
up the Kelly's wanted to quiet help us
to help them make a very quiet corner
you know but so it's this kind of
intersection with the clients that's
very important and becomes a real basis
for the way that we proceed with our
work and I think that that that question
about where our interests meet where
their goals meet you know how how use
and expression comes out of that
intersection is a real interest so I'll
just close this section of our talk with
a
a quote from another designer Charles
Eames who said choose your corner pick
away at it carefully intensely and to
the best variability that way might
change the world more like this is the
head off painted us at the corner we've
painted ourselves into a corner maybe
rather than picking one it's maybe a
mistake to understand our inclusion of
this slide as any anything more than
aspiration you know the idea that a
couple could work together on a project
or be pinned to the sidewalk by their
own creations in the case of this
architecture magazine photograph I think
what's really incredible about Eames
which is that he combined or both of
them combined Charles and Ray combined
picking a corner and a worldly view is
that sort of quality of saying you know
we're industrial designers but we take
on enormous subjects and when I look at
that work and I think about the
relationship of material to the body and
then I think about those ideas being
translated up in scale through
industrial design and design
experimentation to incredible sculptures
that are actually industrial processes
to produce things that are outside of a
typical architectural experimentation
airplanes and boat hulls I think that
you know there's an important notion
about how you limit your approach in
work and I'm going to pick up another
quote from the Eames which are an
incredibly important discussion of the
relationship between scarce means an
alternative uses many of you heard this
you know Eames was asked whether the
design process could admit constraints
and he said design to spent depends
largely on constraints and when pushed a
little further said the sum of all
constraints here's one of the few
effective keys to the design problem the
ability of the designer to wreck
as many of the constraints as possible
his willingness and enthusiasm for
working within these constraints
constraints of price of size of strength
of balance of surface of time and so
forth each problem has its own peculiar
list does design a Bay laws his
questioner asked aren't constraints
enough Ames replied when I look at these
veneers laid out in the process getting
ready for a glue lamination and form
vacuum forming I don't really think of
them as material material in the sense
of stuff matter I think of them at least
for the Eames and perhaps as an
inspiration to us as material in terms
of subject matter and so I'd like to
talk a little bit heavily after released
having kind of laid out some provisional
conclusions some uses in Lionel Robbins
terms I'd like to talk about approaches
and I will also want to take on con
suggestion that our work is crafted I
wish our work was craftsmanship there
are a lot of questions about craft and
the relationship of architects and
crafts I don't actually think architects
craft anything I think they enable craft
I think if they do are making our
crafting things are building buildings
themselves as we've seen we risk a kind
of conceptual paucity I think I think
doing taking on too much sometimes
produces a lack of conceptual clarity
and that's something we're trying to
correct and to work on so I'll talk a
little bit about crafts in my conclusion
I know that time is a little short and I
want to make sure that I cover some of
the projects that are upcoming but I
want to arrange them in terms of some
approaches I guess i would say means
scarce means perhaps based on some
engineering principles that we like i
won't talk about all of them Bob don't
worry but I want to focus on issues that
are a sense the observe observe of sort
of the obverse of craft ideas like
laxity allowance tolerance mitigation
slop clearance all of these things that
any craftsman would try to avoid in a
search for precision but
architects and I think manufacturers and
industry tried its game and take
advantage of I'll focus on one of my
favorites failure a concept with which
anyone who's tried to run small
practices deeply familiar failure of
course has serious implications for
architects and builders I read from the
rule number 2 29 from the Code of
Hammurabi from 20 to 50 BC if a builder
builds a house for anyone and does not
complete it firmly and the house that he
has built collapses and kills the owner
then the Builder shall be put to death
we've had plenty of experiences with
failure too many to numerate here but
with experience I guess you can learn
from failure and I want to talk about
one particular project that week same as
a failure of our own and maybe a larger
failure this is the new haven Coliseum
zombies will come here recently don't
remember looking down orange street to
the to the south and this hulking
monstrosity and I say that in the
fondest terms 60 feet above the street
level four levels of parking that could
empty out 2,400 cars in 20 minutes an
amazing feat of technology may be the
architects version of craft I'm not sure
and we never really liked this building
it kind of shaded our neighborhood it
felt decrepit and in bad shape until it
was announced that it was going to be
torn down at which point we immediately
decided that it was our favorite
building in New Haven if not the world
and then and also noted that REM kool
haus alan PLATUS once told me when he
came to New Haven announced that the new
haven Coliseum probably in better shape
at the time was his favorite building no
surprise so I felt like I was in pretty
decent company in feeling this way so
you know roused by the support of a like
five AHL hockey fanatics who enjoyed
seeing the building and and and a couple
of wayward a clerk wayward posse of New
Haven new Urbanists who were caught in
this really awkward position of
advocating this salvation of the
historic city but not really
understanding exactly
what the terms of the historic city were
in this particular location and we made
a proposal to suffuse the building with
program to take it over with all kinds
of theatres and and and exhibition
spaces and commercial retail space and a
new museum for the city of New Haven
restaurants on the amazing upper level
90 feet above the the city looking
across Long Island Sound recreation
centers all kinds of things and then
that this sort of infusion of life and
program would leak itself out into the
into the city and it would attract
institutions like the Long Wharf
Repertory Theater and it would it would
change the life of this at that time
very decrepit neighborhood we presented
this to the city and we received a very
clear response on it on the part of
mayor de Stefano and you know we we
thought we'd take it to the people so we
made a big public presentation of our
work and a lot of drawings and we got a
bunch of students and colleagues to work
on it together and we we presented it
and and and then in a sort of final act
of defiance we put it in our storefront
at our office downtown and we received
this rousing response which
strangely inscribed in in pink lavender
nail polish which by the way is really
hard to get off glass but you know
listen when when the when the when
government in the citizenry are united
in a position there's really there's
really not a lot to go with even if you
think your ideas are really strong
edifice this is a kind of enormous body
of embodied material and energy in
public finance and carbon emissions and
all these kinds of things we're we're
we're spreading across our city and
leaving in its wake I like this isn't
sort of partially demolished this is a
kind of moment in history right here
leaving in its wake what we now know to
be the parking lot along the Oak Street
connector this is only by the way one
level of parking not for so we've lost a
few things we've gained a lot of the
heel heat island effect and perhaps a
promise under this the guise of herb
Newman and a few other people who will
be here tonight I hope in the audience a
better solution than a part surface
parking lot so failure had a lot to tell
us and and reminded us that when we make
buildings we've taken on a lot of things
and when we take them away we've lost
them I think we can be a little more
inventive than that particularly because
the thing that we have to remember is
that the the resources that we draw upon
to make our buildings come from a deeper
and more invasive layer of the Earth's
surface with a huge impacts and costs
and terms of energy and they're all
fully subsidized and hidden from us I
think this goes to Lisa's point about
architecture speaking with the corpse in
this manner borrowed of course from john
wightman this is an academic institution
I have to be careful about attribution
and and and to consider not only where
these materials come from but what we
see when we make buildings and we
understand that beyond the limits of the
site are enormous effects and if you
take on the energy systems that go into
the making of buildings even small ones
and and their potential
you know that the work of the architect
has to expand / family defect another
concept I'd like to address
defectiveness is a unacceptable flaw
it's in products and of course I think
we're in the business of making products
and it's a reason for disposal which we
have a lot of waste and it's also an
excuse for litigation which is kind of
interesting and therefore worth
considering I think as a worthy subject
of design and in a culture of resource
depletion and and who better who better
to experiment with this concept of
defect then a group of men committed to
forgiveness poverty and spiritual
pedagogy our friends in a Jesuit Center
these trees were pretty damaged one was
destroyed entirely and had to be cut
down the university its stockpile soil
on top of a 65 inch diameter beech tree
and killed it and they were about to
chip it up in a chipper and spread it as
mulch and we decided instead that we
argue the benefits of Transfiguration to
Jesuit community you could you can
imagine their surprise at hearing us
talk about that and talk about all the
sort of flaws that could be then turned
in through the understanding of the
problems of beach as a species the
tendencies of cupping and checking and
splitting and all the things that it
recognizes flaws that are Unseld on the
market on the lumber market and to take
these pieces and to produce some
architecture knowing that these systems
would start to break down and sort of
display their their flaws and their
defects so we produced a kind of a rude
screen between the great room in the
chapel at a beach which has now gone
from being about a flat three quarter
inch surface to being about three inches
deep with all its warping and we took a
large particularly large tree the butt
of this tree that was standing dead and
we worked it and carved it and went
through all the sort of stereo Tomic
processes to produce a flawed but we
think interesting altar filled with a
lot of character is certainly a lot of
physical movement which will take place
and change the character of the author
over the next few years and we were
lucky that the Jesuit men bought our
premise about failure another important
engineering concept is laxity and it
reflects a kind of an approach maybe
even to this lecture I should be a
little more careful but but also kind of
important technical concept in the
control of sound which we explored by
trying to damage or flex or destroy
plywood actually which is designed in
its cross lamination to produce
stiffness I think as everyone knows and
so we went to work on it to produce
these tunable shells for the acoustical
spaces of the fire house which Lisa
showed i'm showing sort of seamy
underside the idea that that this warped
surface would produce the proper
acoustical character in a room designed
both for performance and for recording
which acoustical character is not a
value you want an acoustically dead
space and so we built this sort of
instrument tested it first modeled it
acoustically with a Swiss acoustic
engineer who decided it was too complex
for him to figure out and and then went
into this room and built it and then we
actually did to knit with our client
checking the acoustics a recording
expert himself and then we carved apart
the screen at the back of the proscenium
stage to produce diffusion testing
certain details to prevent the continued
splitting of a curve cut in plywood and
then eventually produce something that
might have been you know another case
acoustical foam or a felt was now the
plywood working as a sound refractor so
that that idea of laxity kind of
translates also in an interest in
instability and I want to describe
quickly this competition for a public
promenade a sort of porch as they call
it in Stamford Connecticut on the
remediation project of the mill river
that explored not the bending capacity
of wood but the elastic that elastic
band bending capacity of wood its
ability to return to shape and therefore
Purdue
changing shape through the life of the
of the building the building is really
treated in our project as a kind of
fabric net one that is draped it's hung
it's actually not supported and we
tested in a variety of ways using
structural engineering analysis programs
but also just good old plain ol elbow
grease a lot of different tests at
different scales and then we applied it
to the site we had won a competition
after a sort of drunken night at a
Christmas holiday party and realized
that the deadline was the following day
and so we decided to make this screen
and and then spent the next three years
trying to figure out actually how to do
it the site is the remediation as I said
of a channelized riverbed runs through
the center of Stanford the army
engineers has already done its work the
Olin partnership has replaced the
riparian wetland and the cherry trees
that once line that the beloved cherry
trees at once line the bank this is now
the newly remediated site and this is
our site plan it's very simple it's a
kind of lattice that runs about 500 feet
along the floodplain where we were
allowed to work just to note the
building up above it which I won't talk
about because of time is a carousel
pavilion which turned into another
project over the three years that we
struggled with solving the architecture
of the canopy and we tried a lot of as I
said a lot of different techniques
looked at different possibilities and
now have a set of working drawings that
are is really a grid shell which is
numerically determined simply by the
relationship of the pins that join the
each layer of the structure at their
intersections
misappropriation has been a really
valuable theme for us I say it in the
fondest terms misappropriation is the
misunderstanding in this application of
an idea we were really tantalized by
this particular sand barn in Northern
Ontario not the building itself a
three-point arch is a pretty typical
structure but the panel lying on the
ground seemed to be a great inspiration
it was pure formalism we looked at the
shape we liked it we liked the feel of
it and we applied it to it actually a
bridge that we needed to build for a
construction crossing in Washington
Connecticut the bridge is a it's really
a kind of simple application of an idea
the maximum capacity of a glue
laminators presses applied in six panels
over a 75-foot span and as lishus showed
you that translated into a new a new
misappropriation of an idea the
footbridge that we built over the the
floodplain and the ravine in Madison
Connecticut at the Green Hill Brooke
Conservancy and that's finally evolved
into another bridge Maori boring shape
as well as as well as material to to
introduce a kind of clear span of
suspension bridge across a hundred and
forty foot wide river bed which were not
allowed to touch because of dep
regulations of this particular important
body of water and we developed as Lisa
described the sort of suspension systems
where we're actually construction
managing this bridge and it's about to
go to construction after a fractious
four years of not that the DEP in
England wetland Commission was fine it
was the client the client group that
we're arguing among themselves and we're
about to start construction actually in
about a week now why I call that
misappropriation is because Luann's work
really well there of course laid up
horizontally and they work really well
in the vertical axis when the layers
actually can be separated and graded so
that the best layers are at the tension
and compression edges of the beam but by
turning it on its side we'd actually
eliminated the benefit of
engineered lumber so it was a kind of
folly in a sense but we learned from our
mistakes finally write it ourselves this
is a house of first test of this idea to
solve a problem for this project that
Bob mentioned the the Joey Verde no
memorial grandstand named in honor of a
little kid who passed away his father
gathered the enormous catchment of
Staten Island which serves the south
shore Little League at the southwest
corner Manhattan of Staten Island I'm
sorry big mistake there Staten Island
friends with challenge me and this
particular site as I said in a
floodplain SAT now and suffered mightily
at the last and the last hurricane as
you all know and the development of a
new grandstand this is what they're
dealing with right now but it is amazing
when the the death of a child becomes a
kind of motivation a whole community
came out and funded not only the project
but the the sort of research that went
into it and has been an amazing
experience so again really just the
study of how thick Slama nations can be
how to produce shape using a really
simple application to replace steel
which is a sort of standard idea a way
to lift the crowd the parents from above
and away from their children if you if
you've ever if you've actually ever been
to a say like an East Haven mite hockey
practice you know what I'm talking about
you know like little kids get a little
bothered and I think the fathers of the
south shore Little League and mothers
too I'm sorry should realize that they
wanted to keep the dads of dads are the
loudest ones away from their kids so
elevated them up so what we've produced
is as they describe the experience of
the show for the kids and and for the
parents another kind of show which is I
think they get to be removed from their
kids and hopefully behave themselves and
so the Joey a ver Dino junior grandstand
is about to break ground despite the DD
sees resistance to the idea of using
mass timber even in this most obviously
simple application for their project
upcycling is an important concept we all
know we're all environmentally conscious
here right are we r upcycling the idea
of timber to a whole new level
think and we're really excited about it
at least for the United States students
for the common ground high school a lot
about taking waste material and applying
it to growth and and this is a these are
red worms and compost that they use to
grow gardens on these are any inner city
kids at a charter school in New Haven
who are learning about agriculture in
the environment and we were charged by
our clients to explore the idea of
material and a sort of pedagogy of
environmentalism I show this slide
because just to hearken a little back to
our time at Yale about the time we were
in school in the late 80s we had a lot
of teachers who were interested in a
sort of phenomenological project of
architecture and you know there was a
lot of mrs. yo yo honey Paula's most
comparison comparison of other Altos
glued up joint furniture joint and a
tree calling it the man-made tree when
we looked at that that Alto project we
weren't actually focusing on the
romantic Corellian history of Finland we
were interested in glue and sticks and
and how could we make really cool stuff
in shapes and alto was an experimenter
and also it wasn't a craftsman you know
as a friend richard croaker from
dalhousie university a couple years ago
when we were touring altos house which
he built in which our students will get
to see in a couple of weeks he described
altos details as a dog's breakfast which
is a kind of quaint canadian ism I think
and I apologize to Canadians and two
dogs and dogs right um you know Otto who
alto who is a master a master of making
you know really evocative bill humane
buildings in some ways like Ames but but
but not not not in the same way of
course he had trouble being a craftsman
himself so I I just want to focus a
little on glue and wood for a minute and
just run through this sort of series
this is a big blue lamp you can make an
amazing project products now and they're
being made and they're being tested all
over Europe and and just starting in
Canada and and maybe maybe in our studio
and with the new USDA tallwood
competition that's going to be a nurse
in about a week and you guys should all
enter I can't
edger intent you know we'll start to see
amazing projects being done but for now
what we're focusing on is the
application of timber cellulose
insulation CLT panels even sort of some
familiar systems to a school for kids a
couple of classrooms up on West rock and
that use cross laminated timber one of
the first applications the United States
coming from Quebec combined with
different cellulose insulation systems
to produce this performative roof made
of mass timber that serves both the
structure and its finish and also
operates performative ly to bring a
daylight of course and to insulate and
to to produce energy and and also to
serve as a sort of catchment for water
much like the land around it and all of
these lessons are part of a pedagogical
project to make us new school for the
students which will fully break ground
I'm supposed to break ground in the
spring and we're wrestling with the
bureau school facilities and all kinds
of things but the main main lesson is
that just alts passively putting almost
four hundred metric tons of carbon
embedded sequestered in that wall system
and in that roof system means that our
cars that will be parking there can
travel carbon free for about a year
which is really interesting and if you
actually translate that out to the
larger problem of the American landscape
suburban sprawl and the way we tend to
build and you you project that through
the potential power of American Forests
obviously not the stature of these we're
not cutting that stuff we're proposing
to cut the little stuff and and and that
vast resource that is a kind of carbon
sink in and of itself and and the
ability of American workers to build
lots of housing albeit in a kind of
low-rise application which consumes land
at an alarming rate and you redeploy all
of that material that's sequestered
across a vast area of landscape and you
work back through the details of the the
house and the way that the students in
the first year study framing and very
all sort of seeming things and you
understand it quantitatively and then
you redeploy it in a new high density
application and you look at the way that
instead of using little thin sheets and
little sticks we can start to use
massive pieces of wood to produce whole
new sources of engineering and systems
and and produce a new type of
urbanization just based not on great
design I'm not suggesting that but on
just simple topologies of structure and
then I think that idea of system
boundaries which is pretty typical to
science scientific inquiry but is
obviously maybe a little less understood
in architectural practice is something
that we might start to deploy and so I'm
going to end with one final sequence and
i just will start by saying that cons
material handling method is little his
workers at dhaka carrying cement and
sand in boxes casting concrete by hand
to produce buildings of an enormous
scale but recognizing that that the
capacity of the workforce could only
produce about a 5-foot poor before a
cold joint had be introduced into these
very tall walls and therefore at the
recommendation of his engineer a goose
come and done decided that he would add
a marble sill to cover the cold joint
and that would produce the the language
of the architecture one of the one of
the most sort of important material
aspects of this of the building and so i
want to talk about craft before i end
here again this is the g co Kusabi joint
literally the hell joint it's it's a
it's known in the western hemisphere as
the fox tail wine wedge tenant it's a
mouthful i can almost handle the
japanese better and it's a sort of piece
of craft daring do you know no one
really knows that when that mortis is
driven into the when that tenon is
driven into the mortise the hole and
those wedges hit the back of the mortise
that it expands the ten and it locks the
joint and so if your measurements are
off at all you fail and the joint can
only be destroyed it can't be
use it can't be fixed but if you succeed
and you make a tight joint that's
incredibly stiff moment connection
you've produced craft you've succeeded
in this sort of tying the knot of
material and procedure that you know
sort of a glue that binds panache and
procedure and I think that's really
interesting but it's hidden it's a sort
of hermetic project and the risk of
craft which is typically considered
something that's artful as well as
technical is that if you go too far with
it and you start to get a little bit too
much into the exhibition of craft craft
evolves it devolves into sort of
trickery and cunning and deceitfulness
and and trickery and cunning maybe or
just on economic terms more than we can
can can take it at a moment right now
especially one costs and the broadest
sense or are the subject and so I guess
I would suggest that rather than
crafting things what we are in the
process of doing is trying to game
industry because we don't have time for
craft and we're not really good
craftsmen so what we're doing is taking
sort of off-the-shelf parts and pieces
at a time when the American building
industry is John papka said a couple of
years ago is not engaged in the process
of building they're engaged in the
process of process of specifying
products and buying them and
amalgamating them in building four and
that's a sort of depressing thought and
so what we do when we're depressed as we
go shopping we learned that from george
bush and particularly catalog shopping
this this mcmaster-carr catalog is right
next to act my copy of Derrida and the
American de true vyas I swear it and and
so I guess I'd like to look at one last
building very quickly a building at
least and I finished a few years ago
it's a it's kind of a repair job and i
want to quote susan Strasser who wrote
picked up found this wonderful little
thing from the 1896 manual of mending
and repairing manufacturers all work by
machinery and not so to speak by hand
but all repairing must be done by hand
we can make every
tale of a watch or a gun by machinery
but the machine cannot mend it when
broken much less a clock or a pistol I
guess in the end I think we may seem
unambitious here at Yale which is the
source of enormous inspiration and a
producer great ambitions that our
project may not seem as ambitions as an
ambitious undertaking but we understand
ourselves I think to be in the business
of repair and that the the processes
that go into the making of a building
even a simple shell that uses standard
lumber racking exterior lumber racking
as a sort of system of ordering
materials spread across the site simple
frames of Steel an off-the-shelf premade
Space Frame assembled quickly on site to
incorporate the shelving a polycarbonate
sheath for an interior lining of the
building that brings a little daylight
in again all these all these kinds of
components that are very very simple to
assemble and to find in a master card
catalog they represent some I think a
way for us to untie the tight
configurations of industry in America
the building industry and to test some
opportunities for for making
architecture from extremely simple and
even scarce means so I'll end this
tonight are a student of ours a student
of ours Brooke Denison who ended up
teaching here when he saw this building
said god it's like the love affair
between a tractor and it's shed and and
when I looked at that little animation i
thought god it's more like the beginning
of masters of sex you know there's
something kind of creepy about it so i
guess i will shift to this vision I have
to say because I think I'm a little bit
of a Neanderthal when it comes to
envisioning architecture that I didn't
really know that this building I knew
that it would admit light but I didn't
think about it admitting light from the
outside and and and when Yale graduate
worked with us for a while Bo Crockett
took this photograph I was promised
so I think that's the end of our talk I
guess what I'd say is that you know
we're on our way trying to repair some
things our own damage sometimes I
certainly damaged a damaged planet in
many ways the ones that we all have to
work on and we proceed pretty simply
non-ideological II improvisational II
opportunistically definitely fixing our
mistakes when they happen adjusting if
not necessarily improving our techniques
and I guess I'd say on the lookout for a
little romance when we can find it thank
thank you both I was with you until you
said it wasn't ideological we can debate
that hold you if you come to our office
you'll find not only that slide carousel
I stole from Yale many years ago but
also the American contributes well I've
been to your office but I haven't been
able to hell after bookmark there you
can be sure it'll be on the table any
car thank you for a wonderful talking
about marvelous work of course I'm sure
there are some questions and comments
from people in the audience which we
would love to entertain okay let's have
some drinks can't get your drinks in
June you ask questions eyval visas that
able they say yes right for the mic
thank you for the wonderful wonderful
talk I remember visiting your office
maybe 20 years ago 18 years ago when we
were building these beams in there on
the way back down chapel street so
things have evolved from then write
about I was wondering we become this
discussion the other days because I know
that you're going to Finland and we
talked about the sluggishness of
building industry to adopt to changes
and to wood construction in particular I
was wondering if you could elaborate on
that is that something that you
fantasize about what is could it happen
should it happen or is the building
industry the biggest handicap when you
move to an other scale of operation and
start thinking about the impact of
construction in the environment and so
forth so I think that they answer the
last question is yes the building
industry is the biggest handicap but I
guess we're you know we're encouraged by
the by the notion that the USDA is is
worrying about this you know that
there's kind of a kind of a large-scale
awareness finally now maybe at a moment
when it's too late if the imperative of
at least being it possible to switch
over to timber construction and of
course the biggest impediments are these
kind of local state and national
regulatory bodies as well as this kind
of entrenched industries and you know I
talked a little bit about in Finland
ironically the entrenched industry seems
to be the concrete industry which is
ironic for us because there's simply no
such forest resources there but it does
seem as though there's movement on that
front you know at all levels so we we
feel encouraged every time we do a
building that is new it's kind of a
struggle there was a real struggle for
the for the grandstand but after a lot
of meetings there was a
endorsement of the project I think by
also yeah we've showed a lot of would
Ava you know it's something that's in
our wheelhouse and familiar but I would
also say it's our way in American
industry the construction industry for
us to enter it a scale and still keep
the conversation open the conversations
closed otherwise the technologies in
America I'm not saying there's amazing
experimentation way around the world but
we found that the systems that are
applied and I think it may have a result
in a kind of way American architecture
sort of looks familiar to us all the
time not just because we're here that
closed conversation is going to be
opened up by as it was when the jenny
building was built or when it you know
when a new paradigm of material
application can be brought to
architecture and architects are going to
be the ones ironically that push that
forward I don't think it's going to be
the construction industry and so you
know what we're facing is a change that
we hope to actually take advantage of
because of some basic small amount of
knowledge and experience with it but
also because we think it actually is the
best way to move forward for us knowing
what we know about material impact sand
extraction issues and energy consumption
on all those things I don't mean to turn
that into an ideology I just I just I
just think that's an exciting moment in
design just as being an architect you
guys entering your careers at this
particular moment is amazing I think
we're seeing that shift as we move up in
scale and frankly the jury is out you
know whether we we have five buildings
in full cds having been bid waiting to
start and we're just trying to push and
these are all twenty thirty
thousand-square-foot buildings waiting
to happen most built in timber whether
they do or not I think they will but I
think it's an open question as it is in
Finland some other questions phase way
back there is a question or get the mic
up there it's
I think you guys were really wonderful
lecture it's beautiful work I wonder if
you'd speak a little bit about the
process by which you arrived that's
something I think its students were
constantly sort of grappling with and
I'm wondering should a lot of details
and a lot of interest in kind of the
conglomeration of different tectonic
things and materiality I'm wondering is
is that sort of an après or I thing
where you're coming to the processing we
want to use would we want to use glue
limbs or or do you work in a way that's
more it starts to arise out of the
conditions maybe that's too broad of
question but I guess I'm wondering are
these things you're always bringing with
you or are you working out to them
incredibly involved and interactive of
course you know starts with kind of all
the information on the table so you know
cited program and client and goals and
all of that and then we you know we do
sort of try to work toward a solution i
guess i would also say that you know
with would you know really we what I
realized is that we started as a
design-build office we didn't we were
not aware of it at the time but but that
what them as we're designing stuff and I
was no one else is going to build it so
we built it instead sometimes the
expensive ideas well that's right but so
in the end the sort of most direct way
to go at that you know when we were
starting out was was building it would
and you know I think Ellen had a
particular facility and interest in
background also in
in construction in furniture good design
but so I mean that's sort of Informer
coming from but it's not an ideological
position I mean it does feel like a
great opportunity to us and one that's
sort of like underutilized still
especially at large scales too confined
mostly two houses here and that's why I
think it feels like an exciting time for
us to to be on the kind of cusp of what
may be new building cartoon yeah I don't
think it's a priori but it's definitely
a limitation it's kind of like habit I
guess and that's something we will spend
the next twenty three years if we make
it to cons age testing and pushing and
obviously they're going to be amazing
changes beyond what we're anticipating
in construction you know I think I think
we came from Yale and Yale gave us a
very formalist education I think and I
say that in the most positive sense i
think we had great teachers who taught
us a lot about building experience and
understanding daylight and all these
things that are intangible but i think
they understood that the means that we
use our physical formal ones to build
and so we had to learn about from our
range of teachers basically how to how
to kind of get the thing into the ground
and what its opportunities were once you
take that step and so that's a bias i
think that we bring to it and I i think
i guess i would say i hope it's not a
limitation i hope it's not awkward
ideological i hope it is something that
allows us to experiment a little more
freely even if the small scale with the
kind of limited means we have Joel
Sanders like one let's get to the mic
down here
it again thank you for such a wonderful
wonderful lecture I know how hard it is
to stand up in front of your family as
you were and and you you it in your
introduction you know made that analogy
between let's say architecture schools
are on education and families we have a
complicated relationship to to them they
leave an indelible impression on us and
so I guess I was wondering if you could
sort of reflect maybe a little bit about
what you just ended with about how you
work both you know perhaps perpetuates
the values that you learned but also
maybe even more importantly reacts
against them from your education and
then I has and then at the very end I
was thinking of that question the entire
time I was watching your your talk and
then you made that sort of relationship
to masters of sex which is my new
favorite obsession on that show and so
I'm wondering you know masters of sex
yes you have to watch the Fox you're
going to love it but I was wondering is
let's say your romance should be credit
blame your your romance with or maybe
there is a fetishization of tectonics
construction materiality to your
experience at Yale yes no I mean I
honestly I don't mean to overdramatize
my background I worked in construction
and I did it a fair amount and thought I
would do it and then had sort of middle
class crisis and thought I had to get a
graduate degree and I'm really lucky
that i did a weird time at Yale where
there are a lot of different ideas a lot
of different people teaching but yes
Yale the DNA of Yale is Lisa's described
it i think is trying to trying to figure
out how building can be an intellectual
exercise but building and and I we don't
think that's the only way it's just
really what we know so in a sense what
we do by starting a practice where we're
actually moving things I'm trying to
assemble them and hope that the ideas
are good and can support the inquiry
often they weren't is that that we can
get beyond those limitations and that
through interacting with you all if we
can start to hear ID
that's one of the greatest things about
teaching is that I realize how full of
[ __ ] i am on a regular basis hearing
what other people are saying and I may
be grumpy about it but it changes my it
turns me to turns the battleship I think
well i guess i would say that in
teaching here I try to look even though
I've been charged with teaching the Yale
building project and figuring out how to
get ideas to building I think I hope we
try to bring in other ideas maybe we
don't do it well enough but I'm I'd like
the I like the conceptual basis the kind
of cultural issues that we face the
social and economic conditions from
which we work to be a bigger part of
that inquiry I think it's really hard in
the first year frankly I think
everyone's just trying to figure out
what they're up to but I'd like that to
be the project I'd like the building
project to be the fourth year studio at
Yale honestly and this is a great moment
well I mean I think are you also asking
how are we kind of pushing back against
this predilection that people had when
we were educated here to sort of be do
it yourself and you know handmade I was
a really weird time actually I happen to
be here with three different teams and
you know you did in three years so I was
here if it's only three years but you
know in graduate school but there were
three different teams and you know I
there was a it was kind of like Taillon
of post-modernism is so interesting to
see fats lecture for brilliant lecture
last week and here you know what the
impact of post-modernism plus the
recession which affected all of us to
you know had on there the arc of their
careers but you know I I think that we
had a kind of real do-it-yourself
mentality and I guess I still feel as
though we have that and what I hope is
that as our projects get larger sort of
more far-flung we have a little bit less
imprint on them you know because I think
it's actually in a way more creative and
there's a kind of intellectual challenge
around kind of orchestrating from afar
or even maybe not even orchestrating you
know but understanding and look slightly
more abstract
way what the project is so you know it's
sort of a I think our career is really
if it feels like it emerged without us
exactly steering it yes I would say but
it's stuff my work-in-progress it's a
work-in-progress okay unless there's
another question I think we've had
enough family confession yeah thank you
very very very much and all of us run
you